[Music]
we're here in Adobe's headquarters in
downtown San Jose and this grayscale
building behind me might not be what
you'd expect from the makers of
Photoshop but let's check out the inside
[Music]
Adobe built in San Jose HQ in 1994 after
20 years it came time for a redesign
designer Natalie angles said it was in
need of a more colorful update you know
when we first ventured to the space it
is exactly what you would imagine from
the outside it was very Bank
institutional like sure and that's not
what tech is that's specifically not
what Adobe is
so when I walk in here as an employee
during the morning and the first thing I
see is this vibrant orange color what is
that doing for me it should have the
right amount of yellow and then actually
to have this happiness a vibrant scene
but not too vibrant to agitate you and
so we really wanted especially after
people are stuck in traffic to come in
here and just feel refreshed and vibrant
and ready to start their day color is
more than ascetics at Adobe
it's their business so angles an Adobe
used color theory throughout the space
to think more scientifically about how
hues and brightness levels inspire work
so when you think about it from a
scientific perspective that orange
that's very much kind of an invitation
for community what we find is we find
people working down here on their own
they're opting in it's a place that they
want to be it's been active since we've
opened it the unfresh color angles
designed a variety of spaces to
accommodate different types of work
before the redesign Adobe had only
closed office spaces the focus then was
on giving engineers the quiet space they
needed for work floors looked like this
one as work has shifted as generations
have changed it became pretty obvious
that they needed to be together so that
meant opening offices up but Adobe isn't
a full open office environment we really
want to create balanced workspace do you
have the right meeting rooms is there a
place where you can make phone calls
when you're not disturbing others a
workstation or a desk is actually about
tasks work that's why each floor also
has spaces for group and individual
focused work adobe has these phone
booths that are dedicated to special
moments in Photoshop sister II this is
1890 the your Photoshop was invented and
they actually have the first version
installed on this back right dude check
it out
suppose a color picker doesn't really
matter when you're operating a grayscale
each florida dobby is different some
like this one we're more experimental
tests to see what worked for employees
so now we're into this more open
environment I think something that's
fascinating about this floor is that
there are no offices Wow everything
everything in life is an experiment we
don't know exactly what's going to work
better for you that's gonna work for me
and so there is a spirit of innovation
what we're trying to do is be more
innovative and to do that you have to
experiment more and you have to almost
create a culture and an environment
where you can feel that in a modular
room called lab 82 named after the euro
Dobby was founded the company tests
ideas in workplace design including how
plants sounds colors and scents can
change a meeting and what we're looking
to do is identify the best possible
future ways of being able to collaborate
and when something really worked ankles
in Adobe listened these booths are
really popular oh they're so far they're
so popular that we had to come back in
and add this whole row
one of the most noticeable upgrades
Adobe made in the redesign was the
addition of two new cafes they went from
one two three
this space is their cafe called palates
its farm-to-fork concept and it really
harkens back to what this land was you
know this whole area was orchards and so
we really wanted to give people a place
that recognized what the community was
appreciate it don't just brush it under
the rug the cafe gets some of its
produce from the company run garden
located just outside its doors we're
able to grow about 5,000 pounds of
produce that we use in our cafes and in
our learning kitchens and what's really
great about it is we have employees come
and grow their own produce here on-site
we bring Master Gardeners to teach them
different things that they can grow and
provide them seeds that they can take
home and grow on their own
Adobe wants employees to be healthy and
that means more than eating well in its
Wellness Center employees have access to
cardio machines weights classes and this
so adobe has this thing called the soma
dome which is basically a guided
meditation experience in this pink egg I
have to try it out we're getting ocean
waves
it's relaxing Adobe's redesign continues
on some floors but across the street the
company is more than doubling its
capacity with a new tower it's not to
open in 2022
this is the new office space going to
look like this space inside there will
be a lot of the essence of what's
happening here but also trying to think
about how people will be using devices
differently how they'll be commuting
differently if you design perfect space
for now for a tower that's going to open
in 2022 you can guarantee that it's not
going to work sounds like the
experimentation will continue
[Music]